this is an intermediate git course
taught by tobias gunther he'll help you
move beyond get basics and improve your
get workflow
hello free codecam friends my name is
tobias and i'm going to improve your get
knowledge today
there are a lot of beginner tutorials
out there about version control with git
but i will help you understand the
concepts behind many things in git
how to craft the perfect commit how to
choose a branching strategy or how merge
conflicts really work
so my goal is to give you more
confidence when you work with git
and to get you a little bit closer to
becoming an advanced git user
before we start a huge shout out to the
free code cam team thank you so much for
being on this mission of teaching people
how to code and thanks for letting me
contribute a little bit
a couple of words about my own
background i'm part of the team behind
tower and tower is a git desktop gui for
mac and windows we've been around for
more than 10 years now and helped over a
hundred thousand developers and
designers
work more easily with git
become more productive with git and make
fewer mistakes
for today's session you don't need to
have tower installed you can follow
along
on the command line no problem
all right let's get started
so let's talk a bit about how to create
the perfect commit
so the first part is to add the right
changes right and the second part is to
compose a good commit message
so let's start by
let's start by adding changes to the
commit so our goal here is to create a
commit that makes sense one that only
includes changes from a single topic
and in contrast to the easy way when we
sometimes just
cram all of our current local changes
into the next commit so this is the the
bad thing we should not do
but being selective and carefully
deciding what should go into the next
commit is really important oh
this is a better way of how a better
commit could look like because it
separates
different topics
on the other hand the bigger a commit
gets and the more topics that are mixed
into the commit the harder it gets to
understand both for your colleagues and
for yourself in the future
so git staging area concept is really
helpful in this context it allows you to
select specific files or even parts of
those files for the next commit
so this is what the staging area can do
for you you can really select
individual files for one
commit and even parts of files for one
commit and leave others for future
commit
so let's take a look at a practical
example
and over the last few hours or maybe
even days we've created a bunch of
changes let's say
get status here
but let's say that not all of those are
about the same topic so let's stick to
that golden rule of version control to
only combine changes from the same topic
in a single commit
and you probably already know that to
include a specific file we can simply
type
git add and the name of the file so
let's add that css file here
and voila
and let's take a closer look at another
file index.html and see what changes it
currently contains
so we can use git diff
for that
and we can see
that there are two parts or chunks of
changes at the moment and let's say that
the first one belongs to the next
commits topic but not the second one so
let's just add the first part to the
staging area we can do that let me just
exit the
output here we can do that with the git
add
get add dash p
flag
p brings us down to the patch level we
want to decide on a patch level what to
include and what not and we want to do
that with index.html
so
now git
steps through every every single chunk
of changes with us and it asks us a
simple question do we want to add this
chunk or hunk to the staging area or not
don't worry about all the other possible
answers you can give in that situation
i don't know them
and i want to sleep at night for us a
simple y for yes or n for no is
sufficient
so let's say this one is actually
the topic that we want to commit so
let's say yes we want to include that
and n for the second one this is not the
same topic so let's leave that out of
the staging area for the moment
so if we now take another look at git
status we can see that
[Music]
parts of index html will be included in
the next commit changes to be committed
and other parts
will be left for a future commit again
so index html is listed twice
awesome
crafting a commit like this in a very
granular way will help you create a very
valuable commit history one that is easy
to read and to understand and this is
crucial if you want to stay on top of
things
now let's talk about the second part of
creating that perfect commit
and that is providing a great commit
message
we'll start with the subject line
so
of course
conventions are different between teams
but generally the advice is to write
something very concise
less than 80 characters if possible and
the subject should be a very brief
summary of what happened
and
here's a little hint if you have trouble
writing something short and concise then
this might be an indication that you've
put too many different topics into that
commit right
so let's go to the command line
and if i now type so i have a couple of
changes again stage for the next commit
if i type git commit
i will get an editor window where i can
enter a commit message
and we'll write something simple
add captcha
for email sign up
if we add an empty line after the
subject
it knows we are writing the body of the
message
and here's room for a much more detailed
explanation so here are a couple of
questions you might want to
answer with your commit message body
this year what's now different than
before what's the reason for the change
and is there anything to watch out for
or anything particularly remarkable
about that commit
so i'll
write my version of that
in the
text editor here
and
voila
so let's save and close this
and the commit is done
let's take a quick look at git log and
we can see okay so this is the last
commit we just did this is the subject
and this is the body of the message
so by answering these questions you're
doing your colleagues and your future
self a huge favor because it helps to
understand what exactly happened in this
revision and what to watch out for
let's talk a bit about branching
strategies this is an important topic
because git leaves it completely up to
you how you want to work with branches
it only provides the tool
but you and your team are responsible
for using it in the optimal
way and this brings us to our first
topic conventions if you work in a team
you need to come up with a clear
convention on how to how you want to
work with branches and you need to write
this down somewhere where it's
accessible to everyone
why your team needs a written convention
you ask because git allows you to create
branches but it doesn't tell you how to
use them you need a written best
practice of how to work or how work is
ideally structured in your team to avoid
mistakes and collisions
and this highly depends on your team and
team size on your project
and how you handle releases of your
software
last not least it helps to onboard new
team members when new people join your
team you can point them to your
documented convention and they'll
quickly understand how branches are
handled in your team
when you think about how you want to
work with branches you automatically
think about how you integrate changes
and structure releases these topics are
tightly connected
to help you better understand your
options let's simplify a little bit i'll
show you how two extreme versions of how
you could design your branching
workflows
and the motto of the first one is always
be integrating the mainline development
always integrate your own work with the
work of the team that's the motto here
and
so this is how it could look
in this example we only have a single
branch where everyone contributes their
commits
so this is a really simplified example i
doubt that any team in the real world
would have such a simple branching
structure but for illustration
this extreme simplified example helps us
understand the advantages and
disadvantages of this model so in an
always be integrating model you have
very few branches and this makes it
easier to keep track of things in your
project of course
also commits in this model must be
relatively small this is a natural
requirement because you cannot risk big
bloated commits in such an environment
where things are constantly integrated
into production code
and this also means that you must have a
high quality testing environment set up
again the premise in this model is that
code is integrated very quickly into
your main line your production code
and this means that testing and qa
standards in your team must be top notch
if you don't have this this model will
not work for you
the other end of the spectrum
is when multiple different types of
branches enter the stage
so here branches are used to fill to
fulfill different jobs
new features and experiments are kept in
their own branches releases can be
planned and managed managed in their own
branches and even different states in
your development flow like production
develop
can be represented by branches
remember that this all depends on the
needs and requirements of your team and
project it's hard to say that one
approach is better than the other and
although a model like this one seems
complicated it's mostly a matter of
practice and getting used to it
and as i already said in reality most
teams are working somewhere in between
these extremes
now let's look closer at two main types
of branches and how they are used
these two types of branches are
long-running and short-lived branches so
the distinction between a long browning
and a short-lived branch is
one of the broadest you can make and a
very helpful one so let's start about
talking
about the long-running branches first
every git repository contains at least
one long-running branch typically
something called main or master but
there might be also other long-running
branches in your project something like
develop or production or staging for
example these branches all have
something in common they exist
throughout the complete life cycle of
the project
i've already mentioned one typical
example of such a long running branch
every project has a mainline branch like
master or main
and another type of long-running
branches are so-called integration
branches often named develop or staging
typically these branches
represent states in a project's release
or deployment process
if your code moves through different
states for example from development to
staging to production it makes a lot of
sense to mirror this structure in your
branches
too and finally many teams
have a convention connected to
long-running branches typically commits
are never directly added to these
branches commits should only make it to
the long-running branch through
integration in other words through a
merge or a rebase
there are a couple of reasons for such a
rule one has to do with quality
you don't want to add untested
unreviewed code to your production
environment as an example
that's why code should go through
different states tests and reviews
before it finally arrives on production
another reason might be release bundling
and scheduling you might want to release
new code in batches maybe even
thoroughly scheduled
without such a rule when code is
directly committed to long-running
branches like main
keeping an eye on what's released
becomes pretty difficult
now the other type of branches are
short-lived branches and in contrast to
long-running branches they are created
for certain purposes
and then deleted after they have been
integrated there are many different
reasons to create short-lived branches
for example when you start working on a
new feature a bug fix a reflect
refactoring or an experiment
and typically a short-lived branch will
be based on a long-running branch for
example when you start a new feature you
might base that new feature on your
long-running main branch for example
and after making some commits and
finishing your work you probably want to
re-integrate it back into main
and after you've safely merged or
rebased it your feature branch can be
deleted
i've already said that branching
strategies will be different for each
team and project it highly depends on
your preferences your team size or type
of project
but i'd like to give you a glimpse into
two pretty popular branching strategies
and take both of them as inspiration for
your own individual branching strategy
let's start with github flow
github advocates a workflow that's
extremely lean and simple it only has a
single long running branch the default
main branch and anything you're actively
working on is done in a separate branch
a short-lived branch
no matter if that's a feature a bug fix
or a factoring
so this is a very simple very lean setup
another very popular model is called git
flow and this offers a bit more
structure but also more rules to follow
so the main branch is a reflection of
the current production state the other
long-running branch is typically
typically called develop
and any feature branches start from this
one and will be merged back into it
develop is also the starting point for
any new releases you would open a new
release branch do your testing commit
any bug fixes to that release branch
and once you're confident that it's
ready for production you merge it back
into main
you would then add a tag for that
release commit on main and close the
release branch
as you can see good flow defines quite a
couple of tasks and steps in the process
in tower the get desktop gui that we
make we support users by offering these
tasks as shortcuts in the app and that
way i can show you here so you have all
of the most important actions that git
flow brings to you so you don't have to
remember all the bits and pieces and
what you have to do and what comes next
that make up these different steps
so if you ask different teams how they
are using branches you will get many
different answers there is no perfect
branching model that everyone should
adopt it's more about understanding your
project your release workflow and your
team
and then modeling a branching workflow
that supports you in the best way
possible
let's talk about pull requests
first of all you need to understand that
pull requests are not a core git feature
they are provided by your git hosting
platform which means they work and
look a little bit differently on github
gitlab bitbucket azure devops or
whatever you're using
but the basic principles and ideas are
always the same
let's start by talking about why you
would want to use pull requests at all
in essence they are a way to communicate
about code and review it
the perfect example is when you've
finished working on a feature without a
pull request you'd simply merge your
code into main master or some other
branch and in some cases this might be
totally fine
but especially when your changes are a
bit more complex or a bit more important
you might want to have a second pair of
eyes look over your code
and this is exactly what pull requests
were made for
with pull requests you can invite other
people to review your work and give you
feedback
and after some conversation about the
code your reviewer might approve the
pull request and merge it into another
branch
apart from this
there's another important use case for
pull requests it's a way to contribute
to code to repositories which you don't
have right access to
think of a popular open source
repository you might have an idea for
improving something but you're not one
of the main contributors and you're not
allowed to push commits to their
repository
this is another use case for pull
requests and we also
have to talk about forks
in this connection
a fork is your personal copy of a git
repository
and going back to our open source
example
you can fork the original repository
make changes in your forked version and
open a pull request to include those
changes into the original repository
and one of the main contributors can
then review your changes and decide to
include them or not
i already mentioned it
every git platform has its own design
and understanding of how pull requests
should work and they look a little bit
different on github gitlab bitbucket or
azure devops or whatever you're using
so if here as an example we'll use the
github interface
and for this test case let's use the
ruby on rails open source
repository and let's see
all right so here we're on github on the
ruby on rails main repository
and
in the top right i can fork this
repository so i can create my own
personal
version
of the repository
and it's code base
and again a reminder about why we're
doing this i don't have access to push
code into ruby on rails
into the ruby on rails repository and
for good reasons
of course because i'm not a ruby on
rails pro
but in my own forked repository i can
make changes i can make whatever changes
i want
so i just did that i
forked the repository and i can now
simply clone that i'll
get the clone url and then on the
command line
um
get clone and the
remote url
and we will
in a second when this has finished
cloning we will create a branch and make
some changes
so this is also important to understand
pull requests are always based on
branches not on individual commits
so we're creating a new branch which we
later request to be included
and uh let's open
let's
go into rails
and
open this in my editor
voila
and i'll just
create a brief branch get branch
test
and get checkout test
all right so i know am on a new branch
and can make a a silly little change
let's change something in the readme
file
this is a
an awesome web application framework
close this all right let's take a look
at our changes
git and read me
and get commit dash m silly
little
change so we now have made some
small changes on a separate branch and
we can push that branch
to our own remote repository our fork
so get push
set
up stream
origin
test
and
once this is available okay so this has
worked
so
we have now created the changes that we
can request to be included
once i've pushed them to my remote
repository on github
i can take another look at the
repository in the browser and see what
happened
and voila github has noticed that i just
pushed something here
and since it's a fork a fork repository
github detected my changes and
automatically asks me if i want to
create a pull request with those changes
because in a forked environment this is
mostly what you want to do
and if i do
i can propose which branch they should
be integrated in so i'll
start the pull request process here so
at the moment i'm proposing to integrate
my changes from my little branch here in
the fork
back into the main branch in rails and
let's say that is okay and i can add
some comment and i could then create the
pull request and the maintainer of the
original repository would then be
notified and they can review my changes
and possibly integrate them
merge conflicts nobody likes them but
they are a fact of life when you're
working with git
and in most cases they are not as tragic
as we often think
we'll talk about when they happen what
they actually are and how to solve them
all right
so the name already says it merge
conflicts can occur when you integrate
when you merge changes from a different
source
but keep in mind that integration is not
limited to only merging branches
conflicts can also happen when rebasing
interactive rebasing when performing a
cherry pick or a pull or even when
reapplying a stash
all of these actions perform some kind
of integration and that's when merge of
conflicts can happen
of course these actions don't result in
a merge conflict every time thank god
but when exactly do conflicts occur
actually git's merging capabilities are
one of its greatest features and
advantages merging branches works
effortlessly most of the time because
git is usually able to figure things out
on its own
but there are situations where
contradictory changes were made and
that's when technology simply cannot
decide what's right or wrong these
situations require a decision from a
human
the true classic is when the exact same
line of code was changed in two commits
on two different branches
git has no way of knowing which change
you prefer
there are some other similar situations
that are a little bit less common for
example when a file was modified in one
branch and deleted in another
but the the same but the problem is
always the same
changes contradict
when you're working with a desktop gui
like tower for git
that can make things easier especially
because it's just more visual so i can
select
things here
and this helps me understand what
actually happened so i can see these two
changes conflict and i could select one
or
both or just this here and solve the
conflict pretty easily
how do you know when a conflict has
occurred
don't worry about that git will tell you
very clearly when a conflict has
happened
first it will let you know immediately
in the situation for example when a
merge or rebase fails with a conflict so
let's try this out actually
we have something here
let's
provoke a merge conflict and i'll just
try to merge in
develop into my main branch
and voila automatically i can see
something is wrong here conflict
conflict conflict automatic merge failed
so you can see that when i try to
perform the merge i ran into conflict
and it tells me instantaneously about
the problem
but even
well
even if i had overlooked these warning
messages i would find out about the
conflict the next time i run git status
so let's do that
and pretty quickly you have this
unmerged path
category in the status here
so in other words don't worry about not
noticing merge conflicts get makes sure
you can't overlook them
all right
though you can't ignore a merge conflict
you really have to deal with it before
you can continue your work
dealing with a merged conflict doesn't
necessarily mean you have to resolve it
you can also undo it and this is
sometimes very helpful so keep this in
mind always you can always undo a merge
conflict and return to the state before
and this is true even when you've
already started resolving some of the
conflicted files and you notice oh god
i'm i'm on the wrong track here
even then when you find yourself in a
dead end you can still undo the merge
and some commands come with an abort
option that lets you do exactly that so
the most
prominent examples are git merger abort
and git rebase abort
so in our example here when i find well
i i don't have the
the time to deal with this right now or
i've
resolved something the wrong way i can
always type git merge dash abort here
and git status shows me i'm back to
normal again
so this should give you the confidence
that you really cannot mess up you can
always abort return to a clean state and
try again start over
so
let's see what a conflict really looks
like under the hood we will demystify
those little buggers and at the same
time help you lose respect for them and
gain a little bit of confidence
so as an example let's look at the
contents of one of the conflicted files
i'll
provoke that
merge conflict once again and i can see
that in my index.html file i have a
conflict so
let's take a look at
that
and
nope not this one but
this one
so
git was kind enough to mark the
problematic areas in the file so they're
surrounded by these uh symbols here this
is the start and this is the end of the
problem area
so the content that came that comes
after the first marker original
originates from our current working
branch
then a line with some equal lines equal
signs
separates the two conflicting changes
and finally
this here came from the other branch
that's
displayed as well so in this case
it's pretty simple in the develop branch
where i made some changes i deleted this
list item
these list items and in my head branch i
changed them so git is unsure did you
want to change them like like this or
did you want to delete them
like here and i have to tell get what's
correct and what's not
okay so
how can you solve a conflict solving a
conflict is actually pretty simple we
need to clean up these lines and after
we're finished the file should look
exactly as we want it to look
so it might be necessary to talk to the
teammate who wrote the other changes and
decide which code is actually correct
maybe it's ours maybe it's theirs maybe
it's a mixture between the two and this
process of cleaning up the file making
sure it contains the
what we actually want this doesn't have
to involve any magic you can do this
simply by opening your text editor or
ide and make some changes
sometimes though you'll find that this
is not the most efficient way that's
when dedicated tools can save you a
little bit time and effort
so on the one hand there are git desktop
guise some of the graphical user
interfaces for git can be helpful when
solving
conflicts you've already seen one so
this is tower where you could where you
can see what happened in the conflict
and this visualizes the the problem
and on the other hand there are
dedicated merge tools
for more complicated conflicts and can
be great to to have a dedicated
different merge tool at hand you can
configure your tool of choice using the
get config command and then in case of a
conflict you can simply type git merge
tool
and have it open the conflict i
have
a kaleidoscope app installed on my mac
so let's just try this git merge tool
i configured that so the first one as
you can see is a pretty easy one or the
second one here error html was deleted
so i don't need to see that i just need
to decide do i want to keep it or do i
want to delete it so i'll stick with the
deletion
and for the second one there's really
content in the file where it makes sense
to open
that merge tool that i configured i can
see well this is the
the change that i made and this is the
change that came from
another person or from a different
branch and what do i want to look like
what i want it to look like i can choose
these changes or these here or can make
my own changes here
so after cleaning up the file either
manually or in a desktop dewy or a gui
or merge tool we have to commit this
like any other change so i can save it
here and say this is resolved
and if i type git status i can see
these changes would be committed i made
some changes here in index html this
here is just a safety copy you can
configure that also to to happen
so you can always return to the
to the original file
but i would actually just commit this
here
and simply by committing the resolved
files i
signal to get that conflict is completed
and i can go on with my work
most developers understand that it's
important to use branches in git because
having separate containers for your work
is incredibly helpful
let's talk a bit about integrating
branches about getting your new code
back into an existing branch
there are different ways to do this and
the two most common ones are merge and
rebase
let's start by talking about merge and
how it actually works
when git performs a merge it looks for
three commits
first the common ancestor commit if you
follow the history of two branches in a
project they always have at least one
commit in common at this point both
branches had the same content and after
that they evolved differently
the other interesting commits are the
end points of each branch
remember that the goal of an integration
is to combine the current states of two
branches so the latest revisions are of
course important
combining these three commits will
perform the integration that we're
aiming for
i've chosen a very simple example case
here because one of the two branches are
branch a here
it didn't receive any new commits after
the branching happened
so its latest commit is also the common
ancestor
in this case the integration is dead
simple git can just add all the new
commits from branch b on top of the
common ancestor commit
and get the simplest form of integration
is called a fast forward merge both
branches then share the exact same
history
in most most cases however both branches
move forward differently of course
and to make an integration it will have
to create a new commit
that contains the differences between
them and this is what we call a merge
commit
normally a commit is carefully created
by a human being it's a meaningful unit
that wraps only related changes and the
commit message provides context and
notes
now a merge commit is a bit different
it's not created by a developer it gets
created automatically by git
and it also does not wrap a set of
related changes its purpose is to
connect two branches just like a knot
if you want to understand the merge
operation after the fact
you need to take a look at the history
of both branches and their commit
history
now let's talk about rebase but before
we start let me emphasize something
rebase is not better or worse than merge
most importantly it's different you can
live a happy get life just using merge
but rebase has its pros and cons so
knowing what it does and when it could
be helpful is nice
all right
remember that we just talked about the
automatic merge commit some people would
prefer to go without these they want the
project history to look like a straight
line without any signs that it had been
split into multiple branches at some
point even after branches have been
integrated and this is what happens with
rebase
let's walk through
rebase operation step by step
the scenario is the same as in the
previous example we want to integrate
changes from branch b into branch a
but now by using rebase
the actual git command to start this is
really simple it's just git rebase and
the branch
similar to git merge we just delegate
which branch we want to integrate
but let's take a look behind the scenes
first git will remove all commits on
branch a that happened after the common
ancestor commit
but don't worry it will not throw them
away you can think of those commits as
being parked as saved somewhere
temporarily
then git applies the new commits from
branch b
and at this point temporarily both
branches look exactly the same
but in the final step those parked
commits need to be included the new
commits from branch a they're positioned
on top of the integrated commits from
branch b they are rebased as you can say
and the result looks like development
had happened in a straight line there is
no merge commit that contains all the
combined changes we preserved the
original commit structure
there's one more thing an important
thing to understand about rebase it
rewrites commit history
so take a close look at this last
diagram here commit c3 has an asterisk
symbol it has the same contents as c3
but it's effectively a different commit
because it now has a new parent before
the rebase c1 was its parent and after
the rebase it's c4 which it was rebased
onto
a commit has only a handful of important
properties like the author date change
set and who its parent commit is
and changing anything any of this
information if that effectively creates
a completely new commit and with a new
commit hash
so rewriting history like that is not a
problem for commits that haven't been
published or pushed yet but if you're
rewriting commits that have already been
pushed to a remote repository you might
be in trouble because another developer
might have based their work
on the original c3 commit which is not
here anymore
so let's close this topic with a simple
rule do not rewrite commits that you've
already pushed to a shared repository
tools like rebase
you should only use them for cleaning up
your local commit history for example
for a feature branch that you've been
working on for some time and before you
integrate that back into a team branch
then you're using rebase on that that's
what these tools like in rebase were
made for
all right so much for today
be sure to check out my little advanced
git kit it's completely free of charge
it's a little collection of short videos
about a lot of advanced git topics from
things like interactive rebates all the
way to branching strategies merge
conflicts sub modules what have you it's
really helpful if you want to become
more productive with git and version
control and again it's free
all right have fun and see you soon here
on the free code camp youtube channel